23 dead bodies were found underneath
this 14-story pile of trash in this
concrete tube Pont tower has often been
used as a setting for sci-fi and horror
movies but was originally designed as a
luxury apartment for the white Elites in
Johannesburg this was during the apart
TI when there was a strict mandate on
racial separation and when the
government found out that the building
had been letting tenants in from
different racial backgrounds they
punished them by cutting them off from
all essential Municipal Services people
started throwing their trash into the
inner core and all the white residents
left the building by the late 80s it was
taken over by gangs and pond Tower
became the center of criminal activity
but in 2017 the story turns around once
again it was revitalized and refurbished
and now it kind of stands the symbol of
urban renewal if you want to learn more
about Pon Tower check out my video on
mega cities right here